hello everyone my name is abed uh i'm
from the get certified team like gaurav
stated uh we are getting started and
he'll be the trainer or the speaker for
today's session oh you can start it now
okay i'll go and mute all your okay
excellent thanks a lot uh welcome
everybody we are going to be talking
about the basics of online reputation
management management just want to know
whether you guys can put in something
with a chat bar just let me know that
you are here i want to be able to
confirm that i can interact with all of
you here
do send a message
uh in the chat bar
i see that we've got praveen who says
hello
and mithali and saket and sanketh sorry
about that
hi with the harsheen excellent to have
all of you
over here
uh we do have a chat box and we do have
a questions box
so it says
logging in so excellent to see all of
you here today and i'm glad that you can
see my stream as always feel free to put
in any questions or comments that you
may have along the way
it should be an interesting overview of
reputation management
you know reputation management is really
really critical when it comes to
building a
brand online
so just one really quick uh what
where you guys are from what cities you
are from
and that would be a great starting place
to know
yes you've got alexander bakash hi
bakash
and today is going to be a very quick
session about 60 minutes
so hope you've got your pens and pants
ready hope you're all settled in
we are going to be
in really quick
so i see our streams from pune great to
know that we've got people from puma
uh uh online as well i am from puna and
i'm gonna be giving a little bit of an
introduction about myself
and
how i've been
really fortunate enough to have the
internet work
on my behalf
having been able to
really do a lot of
uh
growing a lot of selling simply by being
online so i'm going to be sharing
my story with you as how i got started
with growing businesses on the internet
growing my brand on the internet and
what that's really done for uh bottom
line
so excited to get started uh today we
are going to be
talking about reputation management
and i think all of us here are
extremely familiar with google
and
everybody is googling things all the
time you know i know that's true at
least for myself
you know when i'm looking for a review
or whether i'm just doing research on
the internet or even if i'm just looking
at doing some casual shopping maybe on
amazon or on flipkart or on ebay and one
of these websites
okay so i'm going to tell you a little
bit of a true story over here since we
are talking about reputation management
i want to be able to really dive in and
show you how you can essentially
structure a brand for yourself how you
can essentially use these shortcuts to
use these templates use these hacks in
order to start building or further
growing your online business
so when we are talking about reputation
management you know we are talking about
your reputation online we are talking
about what happens when people actually
go ahead and google your name let me
know in the chat bar if anybody is
guilty of googling their name and to see
what kind of results show up i think
that is an extremely
uh good starting point i think a great
starting point is when you actually
start googling yourself to see what kind
of results show up
for you
and
this is how other people similarly are
going to look you up and see what kind
of links show up under your name
so let me know in the chat if we have
anybody in the house who
google themselves to see what kind of
results come up are there any
interesting stories whether you've used
this for a job interview
let me know if any of you are also
present on linkedin
that would be
great to know
you know linkedin is a fantastic
platform
for you to be able to go ahead and start
branding yourself
okay so kate says i'm active on linkedin
okay so linkedin you know as we all know
is an extremely popular professional
network
you know
if you aren't interested on socializing
on social networks like facebook or
on youtube you know linkedin is such a
solid
network for you to be professionally
listed
so i see herox says
if i yes if i google my name it shows
korean flower shop
this i did by searching for a domain
name
also present on linkedin but not use it
that much
arsene says i'm also on linkedin
some cases i'm on blogger too get got my
home page or website when i google my
name that is absolutely
fantastic
that's
essentially the fundamentals of
online reputation management what is it
that shows up in google what is it that
shows up on other networks when people
go ahead and google your name you know
we live in a day and age where google is
seriously uh oxygen
uh starting off on the professional
front starting off with linkedin if you
are
potentially even thinking of getting a
new job switching your career enhancing
your career
getting found by potential employers you
know you really should number one have a
solid linkedin profile because quite
frankly
it is a standard operating procedure
it's a standard operating process
so any hr company for any hr company no
matter how big or small
if you do apply for a job if you do
apply for a position somewhere
there is a very very very high
probability that people are going to
google your name so that's just on the
personal brand building front you know
if you are looking at a business if you
are looking at a startup if you do have
an established brand on the internet the
concept is still exactly the same is
when people google you or when people
google your brand name
what shows up on the top 10 the top 20
or even the top 100 of the google search
results
now this
could work tremendously in your favor
and like we've spoken about a little bit
on
the overview of the reputation
management is that
being online can literally work as a
double edged sword for your reputation
on one hand you know you can really
build credibility for your professional
brand
on the other hand
you know
you are essentially opening yourself up
to the entire internet
for comments
you know when we talk more about social
media marketing we talk about two-way
communication where you can say
something when i can say something where
anybody literally with an internet
connection has a voice you know that's
where a lot of people
you know they get a little nervous and
think like
that might not really work well for me
so i really want to clear these
misconceptions on
uh social media i literally believe that
everybody no matter whether they run a
business or whether they
are just starting up should build a
personal brand on the internet people
should
start
focusing on building a solid reputation
you know building a reputation on the
internet is
definitely the way forward for people
who are serious about getting ahead in
life for people who are serious about
starting a business
the important thing to remember is that
people are going to google you people
are going to google your brand names so
it's really imperative that you
focus on this and you try and
make this work for you in a really
positive fashion
okay uh as we move forward uh in this
webinar we are going to be talking about
safeguarding yourself by building
immunity
you know if you are open
to comments you are open to people
literally saying anything about you on
the internet
it does make sense to go in prepared it
does make sense to have
some kind of immunity
some kind of you know super power that's
going to come to your rescue when social
media
goes viral
okay i'm also going to talk to you a
little bit about ethically driving your
way to raving fans you know
the internet
is
a wonderful place where you can build a
fantastic following you can build an
amazing community
so i'm going to show you a little ways
that you can ethically drive your way to
raving fans on the internet
more so i'm going to give you a live
case study on how you could literally
build an autopilot selling machine
using your reputation so your reputation
is really what's going to help you a lot
when it comes to credibility credibility
and selling go literally hand in hand so
i'm going to show you a couple of ways
on how you can
literally build an autopilot machine
autopilot selling machine that's going
to
help you with your reputation going to
help you with your selling
also i'm gonna give you a
reputation management protocol you know
we'll talk to you a little bit more
about social media attacks
and how you can
literally uh react a sensible
keep calm kind of approach when social
media
hits the roof
okay so excited to have you guys over
here let me know in the chat
let me know
if
our present on any other social network
apart from
linkedin let me know if you are on
facebook let me know if you're on
twitter let me know if you're on
instagram
really like to know more about your
social media habits
so let me know what platforms you
frequently engage on
that could also give us a nice basis
of
where to
look for
okay so
[Music]
i'll go to this another topic question
i'm unable to read the chats of you
participants is there any check box to
tick
so there are two options
uh vide i believe there is a chat bar
and there is a questions box i think
people are making the use of your
question box i think you should be able
to see questions that you know if you
can see these questions over here as
well
and here we've got hira who says i am on
facebook
twitter
instagram and
pinterest
that is a nice healthy mix of social
networks that you've picked out here
anu says i am active on instagram
cinci it says facebook twitter instagram
tumblr and pinterest really good to know
that you are on tumblr you didn't
mention you are a blogger
uh
sangeeth so excited to see what you've
got going on
uh tammy says can you talk a little bit
about slack so slack is a
incredible game-changing communication
platform that's going to really help you
manage your communications in one place
i'm going to talk to you more about
tools but before that we're just going
to kind of define the scope of today's
webinar it is really quick uh it's a 16
minute webinar so i'm going to give you
kind of the key takeaways that you
should be
looking out for
and who says can't see the chat box i'm
going to check your questions with these
uh with exactly on facebook twitter
instagram linkedin
hi sadia great to see you here
because how to get the chat option
so i think all of us are here
we are looking at two different things
and let's try to
get one central place
vedi says yes can't see chats and
participants
so today we are using
[Music]
go to webinar so i think this is maybe a
new platform so for some of you so you
might want to just play around with it a
little bit uh you know you've got the go
to webinar control panel below that you
should see a attendees list not too sure
about that for all of you
uh you do have a chat panel so i've got
a message from
simply learn team thanks for
jumping in uh do look for the chat panel
uh natalie says hello and the questions
sophie all could move to the chat panel
and say hello here
that would be absolutely great that will
help us all be in the same
communication
you know chat box
so i see that matali and vivi and pikash
and sadia and tanvi sanketh are all
using questions
if we can move to the chat box i see
rekha said hello in
private message
anyway we'll we'll jump in we will start
taking
questions data okay don't worry about it
too much let's just focus on
the scope of this i'll try to moderate
between the
questions and the chats
not to worry about that
i'll keep you guys posted
so let's go back and focus a little bit
on the webinar we are
just a 60 minute session today so trying
to squeeze in as much value as we can
over here
so this is essentially the webinar
a little bit of a back story
of
why i'm so passionate about reputation
management
okay i'm going to
jump into our slides over here
and tell you about what reputation
management is
but before i
go ahead and
tell you about myself i'm going to go
ahead and google myself
and maybe that will give you a little
bit about
an introduction
and this is something that i do hope all
of you
take back
because it's really important to
structure
to
be able to have this opportunity to
showcase a positive message
when building a brand for yourself or
for your business
all right so linkedin so great to see
that a lot of people here are on
linkedin
linkedin is
what is nine out of ten times gonna show
up for your name
so if you don't have any relevant
results coming into
the uh when people google your name i
highly recommend building
a professional linkedin profile
let people know about your education let
people know about your work experience
more importantly
you know once you do form healthy
relationships people are more likely
going to leave recommendations for you
people are going to endorse your skills
if you look at any linkedin profile over
here
i'm just going to show you how it's
quickly structured and
what you could do about your linkedin
profile
so here you could put in
direct headlines
digital marketing consultant you know
few of my certifications and badges that
i've undergone
here is where you have the opportunity
to get recommended by people
your recommendations
in reputation management goes so hand in
hand
i think if you do have a professional
linkedin page you do have reviews you do
have positive reviews coming in based on
your experience
people are definitely going to give you
added
credibility people are definitely going
to give you a lot more
uh
preferential treatment once they do know
that you've been around once they do
know that you have gained
reputation on the internet
so
uh here's another thing you know once
you are in the industry your skills and
endorsements people
definitely start uh
endorsing you for businesses or skills
that you do have
so
linkedin i would say the number one
writer download definitely go ahead and
create an effective profile you've got
options to in your education
your ins your certifications
uh
recommendations it's really
too good a
platform
a tour a social a professional network
to pass up on if you are
remotely interested in growing your
brand on the internet
so number one is linkedin that will
neither ten times show up for position
number one
uh in google
you know interestingly enough uh your
story which is a
platform which is a entrepreneur network
you know it's a really popular blog and
they cover different stories so
if you do go ahead and check that out
you know you're going to see different
listings with your name if you are
listed with your story if you are
listening with other platforms that i'm
gonna be talking to you about
your name your pictures your images are
going to start showing up so step number
one is to google yourself step number
two is go ahead create an impressive
looking linkedin profile
these are things 100
in your control there's absolutely no
excuse for not having a linkedin profile
so that's step number one step number
two is if you are a blogger if you do
have
uh
if you are part of a community if you
are part of an organization if you are
part of an educational system you're
part of a university you know here on
position number three you've got a
university that's showing up over here
universities inherently
have a lot of weightage with google
google inherently
gives a lot more weightage to websites
that have an educational background so
if you are a college student if you do
have an association if you do have
if you do frequently give guest lectures
at blogs you know that's a great place
to get listed for your brand because
that is definitely going to start
showing up high up on your top 10
results you know the top 10 results is
something that you need to guard this is
the basis these are really the basics of
reputation management where you take
control to the best of your ability to
watch shows up for your brand name and
for your
personal brand
okay so linkedin is an easy no-brainer
if you do if you are a blogger if you do
get featured on websites and blogs like
your story that again is a no-brainer
now these websites come with a ton of
authority they come with a ton of trust
so if you are able to get listed on news
websites if you are able to get listed
on other people's blogs would highly
recommend you go ahead and make that
approach
facebook glad to see that
majority of our participants here
are on facebook so facebook is something
that's going to show up again for you
now this is another directory
directories are great places to go ahead
and get listed with especially
directories that are related to your
business that are related to your
industry that are related to your
you know personal interests
so
these are things that will show up on
the top 10 of google or the top 20 of
the top 100 of google so by simply
creating
effective profiles by simply creating
profiles that
are complete
you know that is
what's going to start showing up for you
and for your brand when people go ahead
and google you
okay
about me
here is another amazing platform which i
believe is available for free you know
anybody can go ahead and create an about
me page
you know
about me
is another opportunity
that
is another opportunity where you
let people know more about yourself this
is valuable
information that you control you could
go ahead and create a profile
about yourself you know that's what the
platform is about me
so inherently it's got a lot of
information that's going to show up
about with your name
so after you get a good linkedin profile
if this is a writer download
down about me this is got super 30 with
google if you're going to create this
page you
put in your images you put in your
videos you put in as much information as
you can about yourself
you can be very certain that this will
show up for you within the top 10.
twitter
twitter is instantaneously getting
indexed by google your twitter is a very
popular social media uh platform it's
all about real time so here you can see
google's gone ahead and indexed this
tweet online reputation management 10
hours ago you can see the twitter icon
over here so if you are on twitter good
probability
that your
top 10 will display your handle as well
so now something that i do want to
point out over here
is you should have a consistent first
name and last name what you want to go
by so that google can easily categorize
and map this and they can find your
images the more information that you can
give google to link
everything that you own to link all your
assets together on the internet uh the
better chances you have of
controlling your reputation
so linkedin we've got educational
websites we've got blogs that are
showing up we've got facebook we've got
directories
about me so go ahead and use that as a
great source to brand yourself
brand your company twitter
real time
now quora again a very interesting
question and answer social media
platform where you can ask questions and
answers so
literally anything under the sun
a little bit of a bio so husband to mela
boss at work business excite
whiskey entertains and life teaches me
something new something amazing every
single
day
you see that google's automatically
gonna pick up images as well they do
just a fantastic
job you know google is
yeah probably knows you probably know
your business way better than yourself
they know who your friends are they know
where you're speaking at they know what
webinars you
coming now so real quick i'm going to
click on images because images again is
an extremely important
reputation management tool what shows up
when people google your name what shows
up when people
you know go ahead and google you now
these quite obviously are images that
are taken from social platforms
which is absolutely incredible you know
i've not gone ahead and listed out
these images or gone and pasted them
somewhere these are images that google
automatically tags
automatically finds and uses
based on their algorithm the same way
they pick up the top 10 rankings for
your images
they do the same with
a picture that's developed you can see
they're all pretty relevant
uh
more and more information over here the
company that i'm associated to
uh you have an interesting book that i'd
like to probably share with you guys
later on which is on amazon so google is
literally going ahead and picking up
everything that you've got they've got a
picture of your dog they've got a
picture of your swimming pool uh they
index youtube they pick up things that
are pretty
impressive in terms of technology the
way they're able to
laser target you you know this is a
picture of my friends it's a picture of
my team over here
so they picked it up from your story
they pick it up from facebook
so
very interesting yet powerful
uh when it comes to managing your
reputation online
definitely want you guys to start
labeling your question your images
whatever you do whether it's on facebook
whether it's anybody else
so that is a another
super opportunity
slideshare slideshare is a great
platform to go ahead and
upload your
presentations
slideshare is a great place to share
your work
so
if you are looking at setting up your
profiles
go ahead and create slideshare as well
you know if you could even jump into say
a page seven
and you're gonna see that people have
picked up google's picked up things that
you've done you know even eight years
ago
here is
another great platform that i highly
recommend you to
adapt if you are on
if you are a blogger
definitely check out medium
i'm randomly going to go and show you
some
more
platforms that you can use you know this
is medium.com they've got so much
authority over here
you know this is a blog post i wrote i
wrote about
a year ago
celebrating 80 years in business
here's another potential place that
google's picked up you know so every
image that you use in your blog post
this was a team that we had about eight
years ago when my dad and me started
this company back in 2007
you know we
grew up on uh different platforms like
uh elance where we really have to work
very hard in
building a reputation here today is
all the talks about reputation
management and
over a period of time we were able to
get a 95
positive
recommendation for the work that we did
this was a
service business that we operated and
overall 4.6 out of 5 stars
rating
so this these are the kind of things
that have really helped
scale our operations you know when
potential customers and potential people
are reviewing this
they know that you've been around they
know that you've built a reputation in
the past uh here is just another picture
of a team that we grew that is a picture
of my wife over here and a picture of my
dog bam bam who
works with us
and there is another
picture
of myself
again you have an opportunity to put in
your descriptions here you have the
opportunity to link to twitter you have
the opportunity to share on facebook we
are living in a super super
connected world over here
so everything that you put up on the
internet you can be very certain that
it's going to be picked up from google
for good or
for
bad
so here we've got you know basics of
online reputation management simply
learn so google is literally indexing
things every single minute they know
that we've got a webinar coming up they
are tracking so many different social
metrics that it is
really interest interesting to see
what shows up what you've been up to and
that again is the fundamentals of
reputation management we've got about 30
minutes left to cover this up so
when we are looking at
reputation google is one huge area of
course we've got other platforms that
really do matter different social
networks like facebook and instagram all
of these tools all of these platforms
are literally adding credibility
to your brand all these
social media efforts that you invest
into building a brand
is
going to last for
a lifetime
you know that's the essence of building
a social media or building a reputation
on the internet
these things last for a lifetime
it's not only about what people are
searching for you today it's going to be
what people are searching
about you five years and 10 years for
now
what shows up is it the image that you
want to portray or is it something that
you know you maybe are not really
impressed about that shows up when
people go ahead and google your name
so we are going to be talking about a
few of these advanced strategies that
will kind of show you how to tackle
these social media
efforts how to tackle your reputation
online show you a couple of shortcuts
and hacks that you can use to
literally build immunity um
uh sure we'll definitely be uh
let me try to go into presentation mode
full screen mode i'm going to be
switching between browsers and this
that's all there is on the screen over
here
so
step number one google yourself look at
platforms look at profiles look at
google to see what comes up when people
google your name
go ahead and register this for your
business
name
start mapping that out
so we did a quick google will tell you
about me you know gone are the days
where you need to introduce yourself
people out like we've seen prior are
going to google you and get information
you know today we moved to a day where
we tell google tell me what to think you
know whether we are talking about hotel
reservations whether we're looking at
purchasing something from
amazon you know amazon is
probably the largest review engine you
know whether we're looking at buying
books
whether we are looking at buying gadgets
whether we're looking at buying anything
people are going to go ahead and check
out reviews
you know this is
what the internet says about you they're
different types of ways here we've got
here up over here appreciate that but
this is the
classic example of social proof you know
where
people are able to go ahead and read
something about it and then make an
educated
decision
so reputation management it's not only
on google but it is also on amazon so if
you are looking at selling products if
you are looking at you know even buying
products you're going to look at the
reputation
of that particular product
all right so we've got about uh
20 minutes in over here i'm going to
start taking questions in the last 10
minutes but i hope you see
why reputation on the internet is
important uh for you and why you should
think about this as a long term strategy
rather than
quick fix
okay so think about reviews uh amazon
trip advisor if you're looking at
building a
looking at building an itinerary where
you're traveling somewhere
you're going to be looking at
tripadvisor booking.com seeing what
other
guests seeing what other people are
saying about this property so there are
two major aspects of
reputation management the first is what
you control which is probably the first
step that you should think about
investing in
as to what you can control you can
control so many different channels you
can control what content goes on the
internet about you
the second
reputation angle that you should focus
upon
is
the conversations is what other people
what other people what other users
are saying about you
you know
social media is a two-way
communication platform so you really
want to start building
brand ambassadors you really want to
start building
credibility and authority with what
people are
searching for when it comes to your
brand
okay so what's interesting over here
talking about reputation management
reputation management is what people say
behind your
back
you know
offline is
often chinese whispers
you know chinese business is how
reputations or beliefs or
commonalities are formed you know really
quickly uh while we are talking about
reputation management if we were to
simply go ahead and google reputation
over here
what is reputation
reputations the beliefs or opinions that
are generally held about someone or
something
a widespread belief that someone or
something has a particular
characteristic so an example would be
his knowledge of the subject earned him
a reputation as an
expert so reputation just matters so
much it's
about your business is about your
brand
definitely recommend you to you know
take pride in building a solid
reputation online because this is
something that can essentially make or
break your brand you know online
online it's really about black or white
you know if you google certain things
and you get nasty reviews about a
particular product
it's
out there in the open
so you need to
be cautious about how you go ahead with
your social media and how you can
efficiently control and manage
this
you know really quickly i think social
media is so volatile that it is
important for everybody to invest in
building
assets
in building online assets by talking
about assets like your linkedin profile
you know this is in your control
linkedin serves as an asset to your
business
you know i'm building brand ambassadors
like it's a question about
from salia saying do people fake reviews
praise too i mean i can tell a few of my
friends to give me good reviews
what about that
so
you know the that's a great question
sadia and i'm going to be talking to you
about ways on how you can
literally ignite the fire how you can
start this process uh the right way to
go about this what people do how they do
it but at the end of it social media is
so powerful
that people can quite
simply
and easily see through complete fake
nonsense fake nonsense can definitely
earn you a reputation but it will
probably earn you a more
uh tarnished image when people realize
that you're trying to fake your own
reviews do people do that sure they do
is a recommended strategy absolutely not
though i will be showing you ways on how
you can legitimately start
building this following for your brand
how you can
literally have brand ambassadors go
ahead people who you don't know people
who you've never met before go ahead and
start supporting you on the
internet
so having an action plan is
what you should be focusing on uh
it's not about taking tiny steps we see
that we got a question from saying that
what if someone giving false reputation
and on that abort it'll be a loss of
mine so you know that's a reason why
you've got so many different review
sites you've got so many different
platforms
that you have the
luxury of choosing from you know
majority of the amazon purchases or
majority of these
reviews will have
a lot of biased opinions and we're going
to be talking a little bit about social
media attacks
social media taxes
you know something that i think is
important to know about you know
whenever there's too much of a good
thing whenever things are going well for
you there is going to be this small
percentage of haters on the internet
there's going to be a small percentage
of bluffers and scam artists that's
unfortunately the fact of life so
really taking a step back
going
by going on a step by step building your
list of ambassadors building a list of a
healthy reputation
is what's recommended
look at how many people are saying so
there's just one person who's leaving a
review
you know you don't have to trust that
but if 500 people or 50 people or 100
people are going ahead and recommending
this particular source you know it's
just going to give you an added edge in
being able to tackle that
i guess i've been talking a little bit
about social media attacks how you could
look for these fraudsters how you could
uh differentiate yourselves by getting
legitimate authentic reviews for
yourselves
you know really quickly uh and i've seen
this a lot of times
with entrepreneurs and the question from
um because saying can you tell me about
brand ambassadors definitely we'll
give you a couple of examples of brand
new masters and how you could go ahead
and start
building this community for yourself
brand ambassadors are essentially
people who are willing
to talk about you
in public simply because they trust your
brand
okay so the more brand ambassadors you
have the more people who like your brand
the more people who share your brand the
more people who leave positive reviews
these are people who are brand
ambassadors who will come to your rescue
in times of social media crisis
so
the name of the game is to build your
army of brand ambassadors
and
uh get people incentivized people
ethically bright people to go ahead and
share
legitimate real-time reviews for your
brand
so saga says what
uh google what's on google that's a
hundred percent uh how does media game
with that so you know the same way they
say don't judge a book by its cover
you know a lot of people have taken
advantage of really putting up such
elaborate stories
on different media websites
all this does exist
what you really should be thinking about
here is how you can build a positive
legitimate
business of a positive
brand on the internet a lot of
strategies that are out there but i feel
the truth always does come out on social
media whether you like it or not uh
the voice is going to speak so you're
going to be able to spot
trusted sources you're going to need to
spot trusted reviews in order to move
forward
so i've seen this a ton of times
in social media conflicts
a lot of people
understandably take their brand really
personally if people say something about
their brand
even if they're giving honest feedback
there is
sometimes you know you give a snap
judgment and you start blowing things
out of proportion where that is really
not the recommended strategy on the
internet the recommended strategy is to
keep calm you know acknowledge
what people are talking about
listen to them
if you are at fault and all businesses
and everyone is at some point going to
be at fault you know that's when you can
really make an angry customer you can go
ahead and make it right you can go ahead
and
go the extra mile for that customer
ensuring that you know you've taken care
you've listened to them you've heard
from them and you've gone ahead and done
what is
right
okay
fantastic place to build relationships
with people are seen more often than not
if you are able to take an agitated
customer you are able to have a
conversation with them you are able to
build a relationship with them there is
a chance to
switch them from an upset customer into
a raving brand ambassador
okay so
fight or flight i highly recommend that
you listen to it don't make stat
judgements on the internet take your
time to acknowledge what people are
saying responded respond
sensibly you don't want emotions
oozing out you don't want to
aggravate the problem you simply want to
acknowledge it you simply want to make
things right so that you can move on
with your day so that you can
build a healthy list of
customers and brand ambassadors
all right so
you know really quick a few guidelines
that we should focus on is always try
and respond quickly
always try and respond
as promptly as you can
in most cases that
lifts the butt
right before it becomes
uh something bigger than it was supposed
to be the quicker you respond the
quicker you're able to tackle a
customer's challenge the
faster you're going to be able to
resolve
any kind of
uh efforts that you may need to tackle
the technology mistakes
no shame in making mistakes as long as
you're able to correct them and as long
as you are able to
move forward
you know if you do have a ranting
customer if you do have an upset
customer try and take conversations
offline you know create a unique handle
for
uh similar requests and
understandably you know when a company
like
airtel or a company like what a phone or
a
huge telecom company has got a gazillion
customers you know they've got so many
different customers all across the
country all across the world
naturally there are going to be down
times naturally they're gonna be uh
things when things aren't working right
so
and those situations you know social
media can get pretty nasty you know it's
definitely a full-time job to start
monitoring your reputation
but
i would say most of the problems are
going to be able to get tackled if the
company
able to acknowledge if a company is able
to take
conversations and make them right you
know personalize your responses don't
take it personally
if you are a business you know you
really want to have an escalation plan
really depending on the size of your
business if you do have franchises if
you do have offices across the country
or you're a global brand uh you've got
different levels of management you've
got stakeholders you've got customers
you've got employees then you really
want to take some time and
build out an escalation plan build out
the social media matrix so that you know
what you should be doing if things go
bad you know they say there's no
disaster if you're prepared for the
disaster so really keep all your
ammunition ready keep case studies keep
references keep customers keep random
masters all
on standby if you are going all out on
social media
again lucky number seven is tend to go
the extra mile for your customers
whether it's responding to their emails
on time whether it's
you know arranging uh events arranging
um conferences you know go the extra
mile to build this relationship with
your
online visitors go ahead and take the
time invest in yourself invest in your
brand and
literally
going the extra mile to build this
fantastic online reputation
okay so follow up with people if they
are getting in touch with you on your
twitter they are leaving comments on
your blog they are
leaving comments
on your different profiles engage with
them you want this to be a two-way
communication
i would highly recommend never to delete
negative comments
always snapshot you know it's really
very easy to snapshot your work so
go ahead and snapshot your screens go
ahead and
keep proof i think the more proof that
you keep on the internet the
better it is for everyone don't delete
negative comments uh with the exception
of if you've got you know hate speech
you've got some vulgar profanity stuff
going on your walls if you know that
this is just completely out there to
tarnish your image if it's a competitor
you know you know that it's an effort to
sabotage your self-interest that's the
only exception i would make in order to
deleting these kind of
comments on your networks
that said always keep proofs take
snapshots so that yourself learning your
you're taking care of your self
interest
monitor
conversations
about your brand
you know you really want to be using
software tools of a list of six
different tools that i want to share
with you uh before we end this webinar
that is really gonna help you
in monitoring your brand
monitoring your brand getting self-aware
of your brand is imperative you know we
started off this webinar we started off
this
session on the basics of online
reputation management by googling we're
looking out for what people are
searching for i think you should have at
least an arsenal of
assets you should be
present you should have a presence on
different networks that are relevant to
your business you should be on linkedin
twitter instagram
quora
um you know your story if you're a
blogger if you get featured on these
different news websites the more you
actually go ahead and put yourself out
there where they're part of an
educational institute you know these
things are what show up in google so
that would be my
kind of guide my kind of shortcuts is if
you go ahead and create
relevant profiles you fill it out with
information that's relevant to your
business
that is when
you should uh that's going to be a good
scene uh you know another very important
aspect of reputation management and you
know it's really a short session today
we dive into
building the social profile and social
media in a lot more detail in the dmca
program
today is a quick 16 minute session so if
you are serious about
really building a brand on the internet
i would think that step number one is
use your social platform step number two
is
consider
creating a blog for yourself
i think we already got sanketh over here
who's got a blog but for all our other
participants over over here create a
blog
blogs are a platform where you can
express blogs on another platform that
you can control
you know into building your reputation
online so
um
you
know give you a quick example of a blog
and i recently started a blog it was
very simple to do
uh built this blog
just a couple of days
some digital marketing daddy where talk
a little bit about some of my
interests
when doing business on the internet and
reputation management and things like
this
while we are in the process of talking
about reputation management
i wanted to point you out to
a real world case study
you know we've got proof attached
social media is really about
proof and what you can put out there so
here's a blog post that i felt like
putting out there
when we were talking about reputation
management and reviews
so i started off with a fair disclaimer
and feel free to read my
disclaimer to understand exactly where
i'm coming from but this is my honest
frank review it's 100 my opinion so you
could feel free to
read that whenever you like
whenever you get a chance but more
importantly what i found really really
interesting and inspiring was some
unbiased
real-time reviews that were coming and
this was information that was completely
anonymous
anonymous but people did feel the need
to share
post that we had
a fantastic show of strength you know
platforms like quora we looked at quora
earlier
these are
social through websites these are
websites that
are open to
everybody it's open to the internet so
we've got quora over here
we've got website it's like mult and you
can see that simply learns really built
a fantastic reputation uh on these
different platforms
simply by you know making it a priority
by simply
making it a part of the process to build
uh your reputation online so this was
something that you know i had a blog so
i just pulled out things i found super
super inspiring uh we do talk a lot more
about
building your
brand we talk a lot about your social
media platform about your presence how
you can literally
personalize you can do search engine
optimization you can personally seo your
website uh in the dmca program
so you know if you are looking at
enhancing your presence on the internet
if you are looking at building a
reputation for your brand
uh you definitely want to
focus more on these aspects so i know we
are almost our time here but would love
to take questions and get feedback as to
what you guys uh think about reputation
if you've got any questions that you've
got what you should be
looking out for
now will be the time to
ask uh definitely you want to empower
yourself invest in your future
you know get certified
get ahead that's definitely simply
learns uh goal deficiently learns um
vision is in getting people
certified to get ahead so
open for
questions right
now i'm going to minimize this
my screen let me know in the
chat bar
what you guys
feel about recreation management whether
you think it's something important
whether you think you've learned
something new but they think it's
important to really take a step back and
you know focus on building your brand
it's just a quick audio video
so whether you guys can
see see my background right now
whether you can hear me all right
and finally if you've got any questions
would be happy to take them
it is 10 pm here
salia says
no questions from my side
i would say is it
advisable hey are great to have you on
this
webinar is it advisable to delete tweets
or facebook posts if you feel they are
inappropriate so you know like we said
earlier on the webinar if you feel that
someone is personally attacking you or
they're talking complete crap about you
which is not true
which you feel is
you know tarnishing your reputation
take a snapshot of it and delete it you
don't want to
have to have the hassle of dealing with
these
guys so anu says
uh are there any tools
then you can manage your reputation glad
you asked that
just gonna quickly
fit that up over here
and here is a list of six tools
that you can
start using
to you know one register these names
even if you don't plan on immediately
becoming active on all these social
platforms that we've spoken about then i
would recommend you at least block these
names that are available that turn up
these websites that will help you
uh you know
manage all your social media in one
place you've got names which is
fantastic
they do a lot of tracking
track here is another cool platform
the first one actually that i should
mention would be google alerts
you know google alerts is absolutely
delightful when it comes to managing
your reputation online because every
single time
every single time a
tweet or a blog post or something is
mentioned about you that is when google
is going to send your personal message
to your inbox saying that hey somebody's
talking about you
go ahead and respond go ahead and take a
snapshot of it go ahead and start
building your case
uh sadia says
uh how often do you
you think
[Music]
we should follow up
with our clients how often do you think
we should follow up with our clients so
you know with social media you always
kind of want to stay top of mind but i
think the message that you want to
amplify is really critical
what is it that you are trying to say
you don't want to get it to an extent
where you're annoying them at the same
time you want to constantly keep
providing them with the valuable
information it depends what part of the
sales cycle they are in you know is it
the first time they're hearing about you
you know are they considering purchasing
you how often should you be in in their
face
as long as you think that it's healthy
as long as you're not
you know give as long as you're giving
them value i think you should be
all good
then he says when i search my name on
google it shows 20 more people with a
similar name is there a way that i can
have my name on the top you know so one
thing i would recommend is keeping your
all these profiles set up your linkedin
twitter facebook i would highly
recommend uh everybody in this day and
age to definitely go ahead and block
their first name last name dot com uh if
it is still available if it isn't
available then look for the next best
option like a dot iron or a dot
depending on your geographical location
or your industry
you want to build your first name
lastname.com
if you feel that you're never going to
use it i would still recommend you go
ahead and purchase it so that you
prevent misuse of your brand name you
know you own your
first name and last name that's your
name that's what is your reputation you
definitely want to take these steps in
building assets you definitely want to
build these take these steps and
building immunity so that when people
google you so that when people are
reviewing you or searching for your
product or for your service or for your
industry
you've got a nice reputation showing up
our great webinar sir appreciate you
showing up here aru
if you are looking for more information
check us out at uh simply learn we do
have a dmca program
uh
tommy says how do i create the name.com
you know you could go ahead and register
you could check out go daddy
you could check out godaddy.com
and
search for your name your
firstnamelastname.com
and if it's available
go ahead and register if it's not look
for something that has your first name
last name know none of these domains as
you can see they're fairly inexpensive
if you are looking at protecting your
brand i would think that this is
a small insurance fee
that you should consider taking
blogs are really a fantastic place to
share information uh you can look at
leaving reviews you can look at sharing
expert
information in your space so that you
become a credible uh credible source in
your industry you know these
are pretty much universal all these
platforms that i pointed out to you are
universal so right go ahead register
yourselves build your assets
monitor your reputation at least with
google alerts it's 100 free uh there are
other tools
that are available
for you to manage your reputation
because can we get the recording of this
i believe that the
simply learn team will definitely be
sending these links out to you once the
webinar is over
but we wait for a confirmation from the
simply learn tv hope you guys enjoyed uh
today's overview very very short session
on
uh reputation management a lot more to
get into a lot more shortcuts and hacks
that you could implement into building
your personal brand or your business
thanks for showing up today my name is
gaurav rupasani if you have any more
questions let me know else feel free to
exit the webinar and uh have a fantastic
day if you enjoy this do share us on
social media do help us build our
reputation as that what it's really
about have a great evening
then he says thanks because it's a great
session have a great day uh
he says okay thanks good night is the
replay available it should be available
should be sending out a recording
whenever it's on the cloud
so
hashing says just want to share with you
guys you had an online marketing talk in
the swims
institute i am from um also from sins so
they connection machine awesome thanks
for showing up over here
you can see that uh i'm not sure whether
you've got this
like i mentioned educational institutes
you've got a talk on online marketing so
i think this is what you are referring
to so appreciate the comment and thanks
for letting me know that you've actually
made it all the way to the webinar uh
appreciate it anu have a good night
sadia thanks for showing up
more than welcome
appreciate the comments done we have a
great night evening and look forward to
interacting with you on the internet at
somewhere else thanks dr rika have a
good night
you